[Music]
okay so here's a story if you look over
at see the skeleton no here take this
take this camera zoom in on that one if
you see a skeleton you know I think you
know who that is
that is mr. Falls and this is mr. bones
pumpkin patch with the sharpie go ah so
we're gonna be doing here is we're gonna
be getting a pumpkin because if you
didn't know and if chica didn't know
world now as you can see it's almost
Halloween we're right on the cusp of it
anything could happen on Halloween so
what you got it out well you got to
remember is that when it comes to
Halloween it all amounts to who's got
the best decorations whether you got a
house whether you got a van whether you
got a car whether you live in the
garbage so long as you decorate it well
you can win Halloween so what we're
hoping to do is we're gonna pump Deco
and I have enough space I can't right
pumpkin decoration but pump deco you're
gonna carve - don't think I haven't
forgot about you
so we need to get to a bathroom to the
local pool can patch doctor yeah all
right look at that ball I've never seen
a tail go that hard all right you ready
I'm ready
I got my swing given that camera never
know where you're gonna need it imagine
if I recorded every moment of my life
oh god take it what do we do take it
what do we do
you're of no help in a crisis situation
buddy
oh thanks you're so considerate maybe
the chicas poof I think your chicken
coop everyday got to be like 105 or
something
I guess I could look it up on my phone
god it's so lazy oh good good news 102 n
falling your house occluded still
freaking hot can you get the thermometer
everyone knows that you get the best
pumpkins by judging them by their
internal temperature and their external
temperature so depending between the
average of the two we need to measure
them so if you could go get the thermo
meter perfect okay
so Wow is that joking that is not joke
oh my goodness okay so scout out some
good pumpkins if you go one way and I go
the other way we should be over the mark
around yeah we can cover more ground
which one is you can't believe this how
about that one what about that big good
but this nice pristine there who is that
mr. bones
that's a spicy food
what do you want to go in the petting
zoo this place is pretty cool post I
need to get pumpkins careful mom don't
eat the hay but we still gotta find
pumpkins for everybody I'm thinking Ben
watch your videos all the time it's
crazy man
yeah we'd see a picture of course
absolutely again oh yeah yeah my buddy
can take a picture thanks no problem all
right thanks a lot buddy hey no problem
thank you thanks that's nice you behaved
well around I'm thinking for uh maybe
Tyler could use one of these mini ones
he doesn't need a lot he doesn't have a
need to compensate for anything so
whereas I do or incredibly I need to
compensate for everything like this I
like the look at this it's pretty good I
think that's a very Tyler one that'll do
I mean if you find one that you like you
pick it out that's nice
my hands are full I'm gonna get Amy hey
Amy
I got my hands full of coke
to get a wagon they're still pumpkin you
want to pull it or do you want me to
pull it oh where oh oh I thought you
were like for Ethan it's perfect
oh they are very spicy may I have the
whoa those are a spicy pumpkin hmm this
place a fire hydrant I think if I had to
go on brand with any of these I gotta go
with this slightly short but spicy red
one that one's for me
why no us sure so we just need one more
for so it's got to be perfect
nothing you don't deserve the best but I
mean I'm biased wait a minute I spy with
my little eye look at that good that's
good so it's got a perfectly rounded or
it's got a flat if you wanted to do the
face on there that's a good I know right
you've been so good and so helpful I
gotta use some tickets to the petting
zoo you gotta go yeah okay all right
cool let's go
I played a game of value a while ago
nature's beautiful bus
we've got cross-pollination you're good
with that's true that is a nice petting
zoo out there well some sort of
communion over there I think we may be
leaving b-but I like you are they
fighting her in cancer and when can you
tell these days you could course yeah
yes how's it going thank you so much of
course it's a one-stop shop shop till
you drop
get pumpkins till your dumpkins get
pumps to your Crump's a bulge Ector I
love new chapters cool thank you very
much you have fun that's good I think
that goat likes you I don't know how
much goat emotions play into things
around here but I think I got an
intuition for it can you marry a goat
all right you're welcome mr. Grinch
excuse me bumpy all right chica watch
out
excuse me who comes the kick there comes
a sweet ass shot it's good go on
[Music]
shuffle up for them right
there was someone behind me it turns out
thank you yours Oh No do you want to see
if we can exchange she's great however
personality just extra personality
attention I didn't almost hit someone on
the way out of the parking lot don't you
[Music]
could you stop could you stop telling
such fallacies excuse you I like to keep
the truth in this van this is the truth
van and if you're not telling me free
you can get out I spy him alright so
here's the sitch we got our pumps we got
our deepest now we just need the big man
himself who's stealing that it is all
these kids are like this man taking our
swing good
good hello how long were you swinging on
those swings and those kids weren't able
to play no we're playing before I did
that
oh my gosh yeah cool right that's crazy
oh yeah this is all Ike's storage under
here surprisingly more than I expected I
know right that's what that's what I
thought
yeah we did it up right like we did it
real good oh well we got to get through
first before anyone go anything I was
gonna say chick-fil-a but we already ten
this way great news there is no new tear
still interacting yelling I have to
follow up in six months but that's after
tour he said keep up with exercise
because it feels better when I'm moving
and so you're always to dance in the
time-honored haste to dance in the
tornado hell yeah congratulations man
yeah I was really nervous going in today
I'm look I don't want to go I don't want
to go are you gonna be here for the
charity livestream on Saturday hi yeah
as far as I know I can be there for part
of it you're gonna be there for the
cherry blossom afternoon yeah whole day
you're gonna be there okay cool
all right Saturday I show up around
10:00 a.m. I think yeah cool now I see
why you think this will give you respect
oh it's pump time that sounds weird it's
pumpkin time more specifically its
pumpkin carving time pump carve time
pumpkin time hey my let's go yes 3 2 1
wow yeah look at all this weight look at
all this light it's so bright it's like
daylight in here oh I'd like to Boff I'd
like to buy one of your glorious mag mag
not a hum pump
Oh pump I thought you said home no ah
let's get two Garvin Amy you already
know but there's your boss gonna be yeah
Tyler this is your pumpkin
oh this is your pumpkin alright this is
my pumpkin he was pumped in just broke
but that's okay he's good and tired
pumpkin is down there and chica doesn't
have a pumpkin but she gets to eat the
pumpkin see because that's good for dogs
all right have you ever part with
Harvick um I'm gonna take pumpkin or a
thick pumpkin dude push it in oh look at
that look at that look at that you see
that there
that's uh that's the proboscis how's
your pumpkin long yeah nice you need the
goop bucket yeah nice
I wanna do that too
[Laughter]
International pumpkin-carving garb which
is what exactly
newspaper pants oh yes this point of
fact where did I put my blade maybe when
I fist ah yeah I had a fisting incident
you need the bucket oh yeah here you go
worry about it how's it coming along
it's gonna be good I don't know why I
expected like when opening these up and
be like a carcass like this is just some
autopsy that we're doing the rules of
bumpkin international standard oh-ho-ho
please quote them the international
rules of the pumpkin thank you oh look a
toothy grin that's a good grin there we
go oh yeah oh you want one too yeah
there you go ah that's cool oh that's so
cool hey good job on that
where's the where's that dry erase this
is anybody seeing it we should tie a
string to it and then like just have a
dangle you're crazy maybe just crazy
enough maybe I'm gonna go put this on
the roof now you know what you can come
up with me yeah come on just be careful
give me that get ahead I think this
thing can take the week oh look at the
way they bounce that's someone who would
you would want something to look at your
your butt would say okay no no it's a
purpose yeah I hope you guys don't mind
me recording this I just like to keep
members it's a creepy Butler my daily
life Wow ejected Lee I don't know if we
can judge which pumpkin was best come on
the cousins got to be up it's his
birthday
hey hey Kevin how you doing I'm good
look uh we we carve some pumpkins I want
you to see a man what Ethan is here
happy birthday birthday no stay here we
have to show you now we have to show you
we have to show you something stay here
stay here stay here
no Thursday no wait stay oh no you hung
up all right we tried but anyway okay so
carving some pumpkins up here and we we
got them lined up here if you can see
them like this do you see them okay I'm
not gonna tell you who did which one
but I want you to judge which one you
thinks the best this one right here that
that's Amy's okay which is your second
favorite all the way to the left all
right
you like that one that's Tyler they're
dancin all right okay we'll give third
place between these two this one that's
mine that's mine oh oh we always
appreciate your judgments okay I'm gonna
try to call Ethan Ethan happy birthday
happy birthday wait wait wait wait wait
wait happy birthday which pumpkin you
like best
which palm King
this one yes my middle does mine all
right
goodbye you came in last place all right
what was that eyebrow work working those
brows it's pretty good brows not bad
Browns okay so thank you guys so much
for joining us here we're gonna get out
of here but this is so much fun
thanks so much and as always see you in
the next video